you just won American Idol how do you
feel
from the top no
um
that's crazy that's it this is the proof
is in the pudding right there yo this uh
it's I need a while to set in man you
know I mean the winner
of American Idol
is
[Music]
let me ask you this then when Ryan said
your name your first thought was
oh cause I didn't even know I was just
like what the heck
I probably even recognize your own name
in the moment yeah I was just like
locked in and then oh I don't even know
man to be honest people have been
rooting for you all season long but
tonight your family got to be in the
audience what was that like for you oh
so cool did you see my family there and
yeah we're turning up at the end too
after you what y'all have a good time
yeah man I love my family to death and
yeah
I have no
[Music]
have those eyes
what are you gonna take away from this
experience
take away all the friends
that's right Maggie
all everyone over here man you know I I
know for a fact we're not gonna lose
connection yeah you know what I mean
listen Reuben and Clay 20 years later
they performed together again on the
idol stage and they're on tour together
so I'm just saying you Megan
gotta hit the road together I don't
really like making no yo
um so wait wait Megan sucks
Megan sucks
he's kidding it's family it's simply
love
I'm gonna end up telling them what you
tell me everything they'll be right now
what does he tell you every night I tell
her I love her you know what I mean yeah
congratulations
congratulations sir you deserve it I'm
happy yeah absolutely
[Music]